a russian deadline has passed for
ukrainian forces in the eastern city of
sivera donetsk to surrender pro-russian
forces say the fighters holed up in a
chemical plant will face death if they
do not lay down their weapons
meanwhile russian-backed forces say
ukrainian shelling disrupted plans for a
humanitarian corridor
moscow said it would evacuate hundreds
of civilians trapped alongside the
fighters in the plant and take them to
the russian-controlled town of svatovo
with all bridges leading from sivir
donetsk destroyed ukrainian troops are
close to being encircled in the city
i'm now joined by former ukrainian
president petro poroshenko who was in
office from 2014 to 2019 and he joins us
from kiev mr poroshenko welcome to dw
it is
looking rather dire in donbass
can we assume that russia will take
control of this region in a matter of
days
mr thank you very much for the
invitation
and
we hear many times the signal from
russia
that they captured all ukraine within
three days which is not happening
neither with a three thirty three or
uh
three months
and
now putin promised to
occupy dom bus at least before
9 of may
before day of russia 12 of june this is
not happening situation is extremely
difficult and the concentration of
troops there is enormous
but our heroic soldiers is keeping
severe donetsk we keeping the
uh azov
not as of what a zod chemical plan and
we
never surrender and i just want to
remind you year 2014 when i was elected
as a president crimea was occupied and
donbass was occupied and it was
uh
ukraine and me as the supreme commander
in chief
deliberate
i'm absolutely confident that it's
exactly happened this time
well ukraine of course has been asking
nato countries for more weapons in its
fight against russia
why do you think those weapons
deliveries are falling short
first of all you should understand that
the delivery of the weapons is the
shortest way to the peace
because now we have uh 10 times russia
has more artillery weapons more hobbits
than ukrainian soldiers and even in this
balance uh ukraine make a counter-attack
and ukraine surprise the world by
stopping the so-called second biggest
army
in the world which is not true
and that's why for the
peace we need three things
weapons weapons and weapons and first
weapons is the
tanks hobbits
anti-aircraft missiles jet fighter
second weapons is embargo and sanction
and third weapons is
to
deputinize russia and today is extremely
important day because
in brussels we have a contact group
meeting third
meeting
which is named after the
uh very famous now
german ramstein and
we are definitely awaiting uh not only
from the our american partners but from
german partners from other nato member
states uh significantly increase the
effective weapons for the game changer
because can you imagine that the future
of europe or future of the world is
depending from 1 000 unpersonal carrier
500 tanks 100 jet fighter or 300
multi-rocket launch system and this is
exactly what we are waiting to be
equipped um
our soldiers because we don't need nato
soldiers on ukrainian soil we help
please help us
to save europe help us to do your uh job
and this is my appeal to the german
government be shoulder to shoulder with
us and this is the vital for the future
of europe well mr poroshenko there are
some though who say that more weapons
will only lead to a prolonged war
that could conceivably last years
do you think that's worth it would
ukraine perhaps be willing to agree to
some sort of
deal with russia to give up some
territory in exchange for a ceasefire or
do you think the country is prepared to
fight for years
we prepared
to win the war
and i'm absolutely confident that the
democracy
must be protected
and
we this is just a paradox when we have
uh more
weapons to ukraine this is the way to
peace
more weapons to russia this is the way
to the complete disaster in europe
because who knows who would be next
because putin think that even the
dresden where he served many years this
is also his land
tomorrow he knocking the door in the
poland to baltic states who knows maybe
in any nation in the europe and that's
why we
need to deputingize russia that's why we
have a historic mission of ukrainian
armed forces and i am proud
that this is me as a supreme
commander-in-chief since year 2014
create the armed forces who surprised
the world who demonstrate this
efficiency who demonstrate this is
responsibility and there is no running
single artillery shelling or missiles
reach or go to the russian territory we
just depend in our soil we depend in our
family we're defending
our elderly people and we defend in our
future and just want to remind you that
putin
understand the language of strength
if you're weak you cannot find out any
compromise and those nations who propose
to
give some territory
to putin should understand that this is
only feeding the tiger and this is just
creating the president who motivated
putin to go further and with this
situation my request my appeal no
appeasement to putin and with that
situation we definitely think that we
need more weapons to do your job
while you were president you actually
did sign a peace agreement with vladimir
putin the minsk two
agreement in 2015.
was that a mistake and i and i'd like
you to explain what exactly you mean by
deputization
let's divide by two the answer on this
question
question number one
we have a minsk agreement the
[Music]
withdrawal of russian troops from
ukrainian soil
the sound of illegal information
withdrawal heavily artillery and weapons
and in together in general this is the
first letters of the minsk agreement to
renew to restore ukrainian sovereignty
and territorial integrity in the
international recognized border now
and this is just a demonstration that
putin not keeping the words and there
the
lessons we should learn from this minsky
agreement please
don't trust putin
and point number two don't be afraid of
putin and
what is the
results of the minsk agreement we win
eight years
to create army
we win eight years to restore economy
we win
eight years to continue the reforms and
to move to the uh european union mr
poroshenko i still i still sorry i
apologize for
sorry to interrupt you i i do really
like i would really like to hear
you clarify
this term deep putinization that you
used what exactly do you mean by that
deputization in europe
means
that we shouldn't allow putin or russia
to bribe politicians
to use gas or energy
as a weapons against whole europe
to
finance
by russian the
mass media
the
[Music]
ngo
and political parties
putin
shouldn't use the democratic institute
to ruin europe very simple very clear
the same we need to deputinize ukraine
because he tried to do exactly the
things in our country and third
we need to deputinize
russia because russia should again be a
democratic free
independent country with the basis of
the rule of law and everything because
now putin
deliver lead russia to hell
and this while putin be in the
as a leader of the russia the danger for
the immediate attack will definitely
continue to exist because putin is
existential danger for the whole europe
existential danger for the whole world
for all of you and everybody should
understand that all right that was
former ukrainian president pedro
poroshenko mr poroshenko thank you so
much for your time and for sharing your
thoughts with us
thank you
well the war in ukraine is not the same
conflict that it was in the beginning as
we've been reporting the finding is now
focused on the eastern donbass region
where it's essentially turned into an
artillery duel a slow and costly war of
attrition
what kiev needs most now as it keeps
saying are heavy weapons
now ukraine has received about 300
artillery pieces from the west with more
on the way for example the m77 howitzer
around 100 of these have arrived from
the united states and they allow the
ukrainians to shoot farther and in some
places even outgun russian forces
western allies have also sent more than
40 multiple rocket launchers and kiev is
eagerly awaiting the delivery of several
of these m270 rocket systems from
britain which can fire much farther than
conventional artillery and also with
greater precision
and germany has also promised to supply
rocket launchers along with
self-propelled howitzers anti-aircraft
guns and surface-to-air missile systems
but so far it has not delivered any of
what it promised to the frustration of
kiev
and smaller countries have been making
very generous contributions poland alone
has sent more than 230 t-72 tanks the
czech republic more than 61 armored
personnel carriers
and 14 fighter jets from bulgaria are in
the skies over ukraine
well now we can speak to thomas viggold
he is a freelance defense and security
journalist in berlin mr bigot welcome to
dw so we just had this overview of the
weaponry that ukraine has received so
far
but how does it compare to what it
actually needs
well actually if you look at those mlrs
multiple
rocket launchers there's still a severe
need because russia has a lot of these
weapon systems and ukraine hasn't
received any of the modern systems yet
the uk has promised it
the us have promised it and germany as
well but they have not been delivered
according to the washington post the
training
of ukrainian soldiers on these systems
is to finish today
which means they will come into service
in the coming days probably in the
coming weeks
okay so you mentioned that they've not
been delivered yet we keep hearing from
nato countries that they're willing to
send heavy weapons to ukraine but are
they able to actually do that i mean are
there enough stocks to be able to send
them over
quickly well uh ukraine has published a
list of what they need what they want a
few days ago by
podoliak who is advisor to the president
and those figures given there are pretty
much unrealistic because it's
more than
even the us or larger nato countries
have in stock
so there will be
a small number of these systems ukraine
will ask for more will press for more
will need more and we'll see what nato
countries especially the larger nato
countries are willing to provide
so far we've seen you mentioned it the
m777 from the us how it's from norway of
all places and things like that
but the stickers figures us is still
pretty low
well we keep talking about the countries
uh delivering the weapons but what about
the role of commercial suppliers i mean
how relevant could they be in getting
ukraine the weapons it needs
they can be relevant one main point is
ammunition
most probably nato countries will not be
willing to deplete their stocks to to
deliver it all to ukraine so it will be
a question for those companies how fast
they can produce
new ammunition and they can deliver it
on the other hand we have the german
uh company right metal
one of the biggest of the biggest
german military procurement company
which has said that they have modern
infantry fighting vehicles ready to
deliver
but they have no permission by the
german government yet so it's a mixture
of both
the industry can deliver if they get
permission but still not as fast as well
as ukraine wants it
that was journalist and military expert
thomas vigod mr vigel thank you so much
for your insights
you're welcome